[Music]
title 42 the pandemic era policy that
allowed U.S authorities to quickly expel
migrants on public health grounds has
expired
the bite Administration has deployed
1500 active duty troops at the southern
border to assist the border patrol with
processing as fears of a significant
surge of migrants grow
Wall Street journal's Alicia a Caldwell
reports from El Paso Texas and explains
what title 42 is the effect it has had
on the border and what comes next
title 42 is a public health law that was
a remove or expel migrants who cross the
border illegally intending to ask for
Asylum
the policy's name comes from title 42 of
the U.S legal code which is a body of
Public Health laws the Trump
Administration began using it in March
2020 to turn back migrants on grounds
that they might bring covid-19 into the
U.S under the policy most migrants were
sent back to Mexico after border patrol
agents recorded their names and
fingerprints border patrol and the U.S
government has been quick to point out
it was not an immigration law so it
carried with it no immigration penalties
the measure proved to be far from an
ideal enforcement tool it had the
unexpected result of making it easier
for non-asilean migrants to attempt
repeated border crossings so if you got
caught got returned you lived to see
another day in terms of your immigration
opportunity or chance to cross the
border illegally again and make it
through
authorities had already recorded big
increases in illegal Crossings leading
up to title 42's expiration
in March cities like El Paso experienced
a 54 increase in Border Patrol
encounters compared to the same period
last year looking at the Southwest
border overall total encounters
increased 25 percent in the same period
the change in Border policy has also
created confusion among migrants there's
tremendous disinformation and Smugglers
have an interest in pushing people
across the border now
I want to be very clear
our borders are not open
people who cross our border unlawfully
and without a legal basis to remain will
be promptly processed and removed
the governors of Arizona and Texas have
said that the Biden administration's
policies inadequately secure the Border
leaving them to Bear the brunt of the
migrant waves President Biden is laying
down a welcome mat to people across the
entire world saying that the United
States supporter is wide open and it
would lead to an incredible amount of
people coming across the border
illegally the Secretary of Homeland
Security Alejandro mayorcas said the
administration is employing a
combination of existing immigration laws
and a new set of measures to address the
migrant surge
people who arrive at our Southern border
will be subject to our immigration
enforcement authorities under title 8 of
the United States code Title VII is is
an immigration law and does carry
penalties it is technically a
misdemeanor to cross the border without
permission and those who do and are
returned face a five-year ban from
returning to the country legally and if
they do return and they get caught they
can face a felony charge for crossing
the border again
the Biden administration's new set of
measures is intended to mimic the title
42 border policy migrants who enter the
U.S illegally which Asylum Seekers are
allowed to do under current law will be
quickly subjected to a higher Asylum
standard those who cross illegally and
haven't asked for Protections in other
countries prior to their arrival here by
and large won't be eligible they'll face
Swift deportation and they will be
deported back to their home countries or
back to Mexico which has agreed to keep
taking them the administration also
plans to open new migrant processing
centers in Guatemala and Colombia to
create some legal Pathways for Asylum
Seekers yet it's unclear when the
centers would open or how much impact
they will have they're also pushing
people to use the CBP one app it's an
app that you can make an appointment to
come to a legal border crossing a port
of entry and make your case to enter the
United States
Asylum Seekers at the border will be
essentially barred from entering the
country under the rules unless they use
the app's appointment systems
do you have a real mix of people who are
trying to to use this app some with some
success and others saying they they just
can't wait any longer and making the
track the expectation is that a lot of
people will simply make the effort to
cross and see what happens
women
[Applause]
see
look
[Music]